Midnight's Children is the second of
Salman Rushdie's novels but even to call
it a novel in a way is an error modern
novels had plots and unless history is a
plot god forbid this work is not easily
classifiable in that genre it is
Restless in the extreme part history
texts part autobiography part social
theory part poetry part magic part
realism part fable part allegory part
Bollywood showbiz and part lyrical epic
it is with the other of his works a new
species of narration it is plura
cultural and multi vocal and responses
to it continue to vary from the embrace
of critics to the hostile Rushdie I am
convinced is clearly guilty of the sin
of polyglot aney Salman Rushdie has
trained his traveled eyes those of an
expatriate on one of the most convulsive
events in modern history the partition
of India and Pakistan a moment of
idealized hope and simultaneously a
moment of immediate extreme violence he
authored the continuing story with
fascination and provocation while
dreaming of an unlikely redemption for
refugees everywhere this is a parable
and a metaphor for peoples of developing
countries today as well as those within
fully developed countries with failed or
even failing democracies it is a story
which is always urgent and never more so
than today
I would like to turn this afternoon over
to our instigator and ally in this
venture president Lee Bollinger who had
the vision and the fortitude to enable
this large project to speed forward is
his good grace that has allowed the many
complexities of this challenging work to
emerge to everyone's benefit join me in
pleasure and an honor in welcoming
Salman Rushdie and Lee Bollinger
so we're just going to have a
conversation none of this has been
rehearsed we have not gone over this
sallman
says that he loves unrehearsed life and
we're going to do our best to make it as
good as we possibly can and I'm
interested in really pursuing I think
some of the great issues of the time and
how your views as a novelist and writer
and public figure so to speak to these
and how you think about it now I have to
begin with this question don't you
sometimes wish you were a lawyer well
you know I was supposed to be a lawyer
that was that was my father's plan my
father was a lawyer he's qualified as a
barrister in England and clearly thought
that that's what I should do I didn't
and when I left college and mentioned
him that I was thinking of wanting to be
a writer this this kind of Yelp came out
of him which was completely he was he
wasn't trying to be horrible but he
couldn't help himself he said what will
I tell my friends well are you having
said that after that he was he was
supportive of my trying to start out but
it's not you know it certainly wasn't
the plan I mean I think you know I think
I have you quite a good lawyer
that's that's always been my hunch but I
mean I like arguing we'll wait to see
till the end of this interview where
so I think one of the ways to frame this
is the fact that this is your second
appearance at Columbia and the first
appearance was a really dramatic entry
into Lowe library on December 11th 1991
some 1,000 days after the death threat
against you and this was the first
public appearance that you made sense
that death threat it was very dramatic
and it was on an occasion of the
celebration of the First Amendment and
justice Brennan was to be the the
honoree
and you were the special guest I was a
surprise you were the surprise guest and
nobody knew until that moment really as
you walked through a curtain that you
would be there and you received a
standing ovation and you gave a speech
which I want to refer to because you say
a number of things in there that I think
are very revealing so about you and
about life and about great issues and so
I if we could I'd like to start with
that and then end with sort of where we
are now and use that as the time frame
and in a sense in a sense this was sort
of a birth I know births are very
important to you metaphorically and
fictionally and in this particular birth
on December 11th 1991 the talk that you
gave was if I were to use one word to
describe sort of the impression that you
created in the audience it would be that
you were feeling a sense of abandonment
that here you were living in complete
isolation and terrible things had
happened to you and meanwhile friends
had had turned against you
well as strangers things were being said
about you that were extremely painful
and while you were also finding reason
for hope there was the sense that the
rest of the world was going on about its
business and you were being treated as
you described it at various points as
somebody in a bubble unable to have real
human contact and sort of outside and
and this you concluded with a again a
metaphor of a balloon you started and
concluded and how you were sinking in
this balloon and and people should in a
sense reach out to you to help is that I
mean this is your interview I'm sorry to
go on for so long but it's a powerful
it's a powerful sort of theme is that
consistent with how you've felt at the
time yeah it was a very bad time you
know and it was probably the worst time
actually because as you say until that
moment I hadn't really been able to
begin to fight back you know I'd really
been kept somewhat against my will out
of the public eye and not and you know
for a long period of time hadn't been
able to fight my corner you know and and
that's that feeling of helplessness is
very distressing
you know actually from that moment on it
kind of changed because I did begin to
do that and immediately felt better it
was an amazing thing coming to Columbia
that time because everybody got very
excited the police you know I I got I
found myself being met with an 11
vehicle motorcade with me in the middle
vehicle which was a a white armored
vehicle right so and all the other cars
were black you know I've in the white
so there's a very big neon sign the
skies and the the the police officer who
was in charge of the operation I believe
to be certifiably insane and he was I
will identify only him only as the
lieutenant Bob he had you know he talked
into his sleeve a lot and and he was
known for the day as Hudson commander
that was his name
Roger Hudson commander Wilson look out
yes Roger copy that and I mean at you my
literary agents Andrew Wylie who was
with me in this vehicle said it was the
greatest day of his life
you know streaking down 125th streets in
an 11 vehicle motorcade with the whole
of Harlem on the street for me was less
pleasant but I'm glad to have brought
him some pleasure he I said to
lieutenant Bob I said lieutenant Bob
this is a lot you know he said it's what
we do for Arafat
at this point what it's like to be us
around fires in New York but I said well
I said suppose you know what would you
do for the president and he said well
sir for the president we'd closed down a
lot of these side streets here but in
your case we didn't want to do that
because we thought it would look too
conspicuous it was just crazy you know
the snipers on rooftops oh it was but
then as I say from that point on I did
feel able to begin to you know to begin
the kind of political and intellectual
fight back against that threat and I
want you to be true you mentioned that
that I lost friend actually didn't lose
that many friends
exactly in fact I had somewhat the
opposite experience of my friends coming
much closer to me and actually making
friends as a result of the threats
against me there were some I mean there
were some writers who who broke right so
they're really surprisingly few at you
know I can count them all on fingers one
hand list you know John Berger and John
McCrae and they still got some fingers
left over there's up there
they were very actually very few writers
who a roll-down children's writer
I know fascist and you see my
dead person anyway he was nasty but
actually the literary community on the
whole was astonishing in its solidarity
given that the military community in
general is not noted for its solidarity
I mean that it's a that it's quite a
separated separation you know
individualist and even infighting and
rival Rus community you know within this
particular case I think because people
could see that something serious was at
issue actually did you know abandonment
you said yeah I politically certainly
that was a moment where I felt nobody
really had any energy to solve oh and
and that it was much easier to sweep me
under the carpet and hope I went away
you know and that's why it's one of the
reasons it took so long I mean
interestingly when the government's
changed you know when when they stopped
being conservative government in Britain
and you know first Thatcher and then and
then John Major were replaced by the
Labour government the Blair government
and when the you know Bush one was
replaced by Clinton yeah it really did
change everything because suddenly in
both countries there was a political
will to resolve the matter and as a
result rather rapidly of what results
and which and what it showed me there
could have been done years before
if only anybody had bothered to do it
you know but I mean I remember coming
shortly after that Columbia visit I was
able to go to Washington to speak at a
free speech event there and during that
time people tried to arrange political
meetings for me at the george bush
senior White House and completely failed
and and that memorable thing of Marlin
Fitzwater
announced that he saw no reason why
President Bush should meet me because
after all I was just a writer on a book
tour so and that was the kind of
characteristic attitude of that
presidency that it changed dramatically
when the Clinton came to power so let me
just pursue that for a second all right
I don't want to be too so
about this but when you read the talk
that you gave it has a solemn very
abandoned sort of feel to it I mean you
you talk about that your life that this
had been a degree course in
worthlessness and and I'm wondering
about the relationship of humor and
these feelings for you and I'm
interested in them in how it translates
into your writing and into your because
I think you know there's a strong sense
in reading your writings and in
listening to you that it's somehow that
combination of really deep deep issues
and personal things personal deep
feelings and a sort of very airy
humorous sense of the world as well and
is there would you say that's right yeah
yeah I would say that's right I think
yes I'd forgotten having written that
thing about about the degree course at
worthlessness it did I mean it strikes
me as you quote it that I obviously was
in quite a depressed frame of mind to
have written that sentence and said that
sentence but it was partly because it
was it's it's hard to remember now
because because
thank goodness life isn't like that
anymore but but there were at that time
everybody had an opinion about me
everybody and m'p inion was not based on
on knowing my work or having met me or
having heard anything I'd said or seen
me on television or it was based on
nothing you know and yet everybody
hadn't you could have stopped you know a
taxi driver in the street of any city of
the world and said what do you think of
some understanding had a feed of had a
point of view you know and and that was
a alarming thing to feel right you know
just
how did that happen you know and many of
those views were negative prey and what
was being published in the newspapers
was in many cases and I'm not now even
talking about a kind of Islamic attack I
mean that's one thing right or an
Islamist attack right that's one thing
but just at the level of newspaper
commentary there was people get tired of
saying poor guy he's in danger right
that not very rapidly people start
looking for another angle and the
interesting I go is what did he do you
know right as my English teacher right
they dug up my old English teacher from
from high school who gave what I
consider to be the best quote of the
whole thing he said who'd have thought
such a nice quiet boy could get in so
much trouble
but he's wrong about nice quiet moment
there but it was horrified horrified to
have my character reinvented for me
every day 20 different ways to have my
motives described for me in ways which I
didn't recognize to have my integrity
questioned almost by the minute to have
my you know my writing torn to pieces in
front of my eyes after you know 15 years
of working as a writer to discover that
suddenly you had no money in the bank
you know that you've been I mean the
static message was my fifth novel my
fifth book and so it wasn't that I just
sort of arrived from nowhere and but it
seemed as if I had it's even as if I
nothing I had done before existed right
and there was just suddenly this thing I
mean this is this is one of the things
you say you said after describing really
the horrendous sort of conditions that
you had been subjected to you sort of
ask yourself the question isn't there
something you may think there's
something I could do about this so
here's the paragraph you may ask why I'm
so sure there's nothing I can do
help myself at the end of 1990
dispirited and demoralized feeling
abandoned that's probably where I got
the word abandoned from even then in
consequence of the British government's
decision to patch things up with Iran
and with my marriage at an end
faced by deepest grief my unquenchable
sorrow and having been torn away from
cast out of the cultures and societies
from which I'd always drawn my strength
and inspiration that is the broad
community of British Asians and the
broader community of Indian Muslims I
determined to make peace with islem even
at the cost of my pride which I want to
get to but I mean that certainly conveys
as very powerfully a sense of
dislocation and abandonment so and and
when you think about what you I mean you
think about midnight stone you think
about the partitioning you think I mean
how much of this is of sort of critical
importance to your view of the world
well I think it's it's it falls into the
category of be careful what you wish for
yeah because because I think clearly the
subject of dislocation migration
fracturing etc I mean that's what I was
writing about it long before any of this
happened to me you know the in
Midnight's Children when the doctor at
the beginning falls in love with this
woman through we sees only in bits
through a hole in a bedsheet
that in a way that fracturing of the
woman you know and her assembly in his
mind over a period of time right bit by
bit you know he's gonna lose her
together in his imagination and then
falls in love with it that was in a way
also a figure of how the whole book was
constructed you know as the world seen
in fragments and and then in some way
united by the imagination of the what
the writer and yeah also of the reader
so I was that in shame there's a whole
riff in there somewhere about when I
remember John Fowles has a sentence in
one of his novels in which he speaks
about how the only thing that man
is what he calls whole site you know he
says if you don't have whole site that
all the rest is sort of meaningless and
and I remember but I read that sort of
wanting to argue with it as a sentence
you know because it seemed to me that
one of the things we don't have anymore
his whole site you know the world has
become too fragmented and disputed a
territory for anybody to be able to
claim to see everything it's to see
everything that kind of Renaissance man
idea of being able to have the whole of
knowledge at your disposal right is no
longer possible right I mean partly
because there's too much knowledge and
partly because it's too argued over
right we can't we can't even agree about
what is the case you know anymore so so
so it seemed to me that it again against
that foul Xion idea of whole site I
wanted to invent a kind of a kind of
broken mirror you know a kind of
fractured reality yes and to see what
those pieces could show us and then you
know and then it happened to my life so
of course you know it was it was a very
scary thing because one of the ways in
which I can't remember if it was in that
essay or elsewhere but it felt like
somebody broke my picture of the world
you know we all live inside a picture of
the world right which is which is how we
think things are you know when somebody
smashes that one way of describing that
is insanity yeah you know if you if you
don't have a picture of the world you're
sort of crazy right yeah and and you
have to begin to put it back together
and that's that's what I had to do in
those years right so one of the things
that you speak to then and now and it
just makes me extremely happy to hear
you talk about it is freedom of speech
and you have a statement in here which I
just I mean it's just wonderful you say
at the end of your talk in 1991 that
free speech is a non-starter says one of
my Islamic extremist opponents
no sir you say it is not that free
speech is the whole thing the whole
ballgame free speech is life itself and
I wonder if we could talk about that a
little bit that is why is freedom of
speech what what made you think that
freedom of speech is the whole thing and
I guess the the larger frame in which I
I would like to sort of pursue this is
that a hell of a lot of the world does
not think that freedom of speech is the
whole thing and one of the great issues
of our time is to what extent will sort
of Western values be insisted upon or
imposed upon other societies in the
world that do not accept those values
and liberalism has the kind of in free
speech has the kind of paradox in it
because a lot of what freedom of speech
liberalism is about is having very
active imagination being able to put
yourself in other people's positions and
so on that's the basis of tolerance and
that's the basis of of a lot of what we
take to be Western values and yet there
are some things that we think we should
insist upon and one of those is free
speech the very thing that has is its
core sort of trying to understand other
points of view is something we're not
prepared to give up on and that means at
the end of the day we sort of have to
have an argument for why that kind of
value is something that we should insist
upon and you take that position free
speech is life itself it's the whole
ballgame it's the whole thing and you as
the one of the most powerful symbols in
the modern world
of the denial of free speech because of
the death threat have a really sort of
an unusual perspective it seems to me on
the importance of that so what I'd like
to invite you to do is to talk about why
free speech is the whole ball game why
it is life itself why it is something
that we should insist upon how long have
you got
it's just on the subject of the death
threat I just thought you know in
parentheses it would be worth saying
that that was one particular battle hard
as it was to fight that in fact we like
win right you know that they tried to
suppress a book the book was not
suppressed they tried to suppress the
writer the writer was not suppressed
it's you know it was a difficult battle
as I say we I mean you know lots of
people but their readers but a lot of
people paid big costs including you
especially nevertheless very good to win
because the operating tables on the lose
and just in you know in the matter of
the ayatollah khomeini one of us is dead
but just that's in parentheses him here
but free speech that was an example of
you speak here's what i think first of
all why it began came up I mean you're
right that I became I was obliged to
learn about free speech as an issue yeah
by the process of somebody tried to take
mine away and I think that's not that
unusual because you know when there's
enough air to breathe it seems
ridiculous to be carrying around
placards to say how it's important to
have air to breathe right you know
because you've all got it you know so
what's the story what's the subject you
know what's the beef it's when somebody
starts turning off the air supply that
you suddenly notice that it's pretty
important to be able to breathe and you
start making a noise about it and that's
really I felt what happened to me
somebody started turning off the air
supply and I became suddenly extremely
conscious
of what I had previously just taken four
grunts you know I mean the going in
position writing The Satanic Verses was
this was that this came out of material
that was my life material and we belong
to be as much at the belong to anyone
else and that I had a perfect right to
approach it and write about it and
explore it anyway I chose that was going
in position
they were clearly people who disagree
with that so but that made me
first of all aware of how automatic that
going in position had been right you
know and how and the kind of strength of
questioning that it then came under
because you're right it's plenty of
people who don't think like right and I
guess I'd give you a theoretical and
practical other kind of as it were
circumstantial answer I think the
theoretical answer is and why I said you
know the whole ball game and life itself
is not because of what what what you
called Western values because I would
actually I don't particularly think of
free speeches in Western value I think
it's something which everywhere I've
been in the world people enjoy indulging
it right now and don't like it when
they're prevented from doing so you know
I've been I've been in Pakistan during
military dictatorships people didn't
enjoy that you know I've been in India
during the in Oregon the emergency
people were very upset about about the
censorship but they didn't feel that
they were so you think you you think
freedom of speech is a universal desire
such things as universal values is there
such a thing as a human value which is
not culture specific no and and my view
is that one way of approaching that
question is to look at our actual nature
as human beings and what is it that is
required for us to be the beings that we
are you know and and since one of the
things we are is as far as we know the
only self conscious creature in the
world the only one that is actually a
bit able able to discuss itself to
imagine itself you know and have ideas
about itself and so on it is very
important for such a
creature to be able to go through that
process which is a part of his essential
nature know well as far as I know unique
in the Indus
storytelling animals you know dolphins
as far as one knows don't don't tell
each other stories maybe they do as Saul
Bellow once said about something else
you know I'm waiting for the great
dolphin literature so you know the case
is not proven I don't when I say
storytelling animals I also don't just
mean that we write stories I mean that
in a way we define ourselves by stories
you know an example that I sometimes use
about this is the family inside a family
there are family stories knowing the
stories of the family is an important
part of belonging to the family when you
and these can be very weird family
stories which you don't tell Outsiders
so much and when people join either when
a child is born or somebody marries into
the family or whatever it may be
gradually they are told the stories of
the family and then they know those
stories they are members of the family
you know and in the end you know inside
the family when we die and generations
move on what in a way what remains of us
is a story you know we become part of
that of that group of stories so you
know so we are people who exist in
stories and by stories personally I'm
not talking about what writers do I'm
talking about what individuals do so
given that so much of our deepest nature
centers around the idea of self
discussion and of description through
story if somebody tries to control that
by deciding how you may speak and what
you may speak about it what is
permissible and not from this rule we
simply in my view cannot be ourselves
you know and and that's why I think I
would offer it as a human value and not
as a cultural specific value but some
but some stories that people tell are
very offensive to other people's stories
yeah that's okay that's all right
you know I mean lots of stuff and
doesn't mean you have to shut them up
you know this is what let me said
because this is the other thing I was
gonna say that which I think odds of the
question this the practical example or
thing that happened to me after the
Hawaii five-o in Pakistan was that there
is a movie made about me a movie called
international guerrillas and and the
International guerrillas were a kind of
proto Al Qaeda group who were the heroes
of the film and whose job was to
assassinate me I was then I was dressed
in a very villainous series of kind of
series safari suits and the camera
always started at my feet and pans
slowly upward so there was a lot of
safari suit very offensive to me fashion
note anyway I mean while in the same
film was shown living in what looked
like you know the Philippines guarded by
what they look very like Mossad you know
and I had a whiskey bottle in this hand
and a whip in this hand and was
sometimes a sword and there's a moment
of high unintentional comedy in the film
where one of the international guerillas
is captured you know by the Israeli
Secret Service and is brought to my
island paradise that is tied like this
between palm trees you know and then I
you know with him and you know I torture
it with my scimitar and drinking whiskey
while I'm doing it
in my series safari thing and when I've
done that for a while you know what I've
sated but I've slaked my bloodlust I say
well the character plainly says take him
away and read to him from the Satanic
Verses
all night anyway at the end of this film
in fact I do get killed so you know it's
it's sort of I get killed by a divine
intervention my kind of Thunderbolt
anyway I get fried so very offensive
many ways and but well they try to bring
it to England and the distributor's went
to get a certificate for it and clearly
the the the what's called the British
Board of Film classification censors
body were given legal advice that the
film is of nineteen thousand waves
defamatory and that if they gave it a
certificate I consume them as well
because they would become party to the
defamation by giving it a certificate
right so they refused to the certificate
I then come into the problem that I'm
writing a free speech battle I'm being
defended by an active censorship
right so I had to write a formal legal
letter to the British Board of Film
classification foregoing my legal right
of suing said I will not take lawsuit
out you must give this film a
certificate which they do eventually did
and the producers booked very big
cinemas of two thousand seats cinema in
in town of Bradford in Yorkshire which
is the largest Muslim population in
Britain and nobody went nobody with
nobody wanted to see a bad movie you
know I had that film being banned it
would have become a hot video it would
have its power would it be multiplying
right it was wonderful to me
demonstration of the free speech
position which is that people are
actually able to make up their own minds
that you could just put the stuff out
there even if it's offensive to you et
cetera and people broadly speaking have
good sense
you know even if the even if they being
told something about me which they might
even or sympathize me they still don't
want to pay you know ten dollars to see
a rubbish EB and and so I read that
broadly speaking became my view let let
it be there
let me there the best way of arguing
with it is if it's out there right the
ideas don't cease to exist because you
suppress them right let's let's come
back to that let's move let's take the
next sort of subject which is very much
related to that and one of the again
great issues of the moment and of the
time and that is the relationship of
religion to political and social life
and I think many let me just put it in a
more a personal sense I think there is a
I have the sense that religion is
directly in any bit put it this way
there are very serious problems we are
facing in the world from a to close
connection between religious beliefs and
political life and I would like to ask
you to reflect on that because again
this is very much a matter that you have
written about thought about a lot in the
talk at Columbia 1991 you say that you
were very much committed to a secular
Muslim kind of view of the world and
life and very concerned about the risks
of sort of actually existing Islamic
culture religious culture moving into
political life as you called it what do
you think about that as as background to
come from in the to come from an Indian
Muslim background right
I had has two aspects because both
Muslims are minority in their own
communities that's it's a different
experience than being in a country where
Muslims are the majority or indeed are
the whole population almost so and in
India the Muslim community always from
the very early point in the nationalist
movement accepted secular values because
those were the values devised by Nehru
and Gandhi as a way of protecting
minorities you know from the 85 percent
Hindu majority and it was believed that
if the Constitution of India were to be
in some way religious in character I did
by by the very large in the majority
that would be extremely destabilizing
for community relations and so on and
therefore the country should be
secularist in order to protect
minorities of whom of course the Muslims
are by far the biggest minority I mean
roughly speaking a hundred million
Muslims in India roughly speaking eight
hundred and fifty million right Hindus
and roughly speaking you know fifty
fifty million everyone else so very very
big minority and so you grew up in an
Indian Muslim family you were quite
naturally secularized it wasn't right it
wasn't a big subject and certainly you
know in those early years two first two
or two twenty-five years of Indian
independence when the Indian Congress
party more or less had the political
support of the Muslim community it was a
very secularized right so there's that I
mean the other thing is that I just I
mean I grew up in a family without much
religion just you know the ordinary
level but my parents didn't seem to be
particularly religious people and I'm
grateful to them for that because they
just let me off a particular hook you
know and it's it was well this one of
the strange things to me and I've
discussed this with with writers from
all over the Muslim world really writers
from Lebanon and Egypt and Syria etc and
one things that we've been saying is if
you look at the cultural life of the
great cities of the Muslim world fifty
years ago look at it in the late 50s
look at Beirut great city right great
cosmopolitan city look at Damascus there
are right
Lahore you know these were great cities
with vibrant cultures they were open
cities they had they had a culture of
discussion and argument and disputation
and etc what happened you know what
happened this is and okay we can blame
superpower politics for a share of that
and of course that's so right you know
right but that's not the whole story
right you know this is a story of
cultural decay which you can't escape if
you look around what these what these
cultures were half a century ago and
where they are now you know just I've
talked about culture I'm not talking
about you know economics or politics I'm
talking about how people lived in a
place understand you know and these were
tolerant open society in a way that so
in my lifetime that decline has been in
my view shocking you know having said
that religion in politics that's not a
subject exclusive to Islam absolutely I
mean last year I was for mysterious
reasons invited in Washington to address
to address a group of Democrat senators
and a group of Republican senators about
you know the president discontents right
I mean at that time al Qaeda in
Afghanistan and so on one of the things
that really struck me as a difference
cultural difference between the
Democrats and the Republicans that I met
was that the Republicans spoke more or
less entirely in religious language more
or less entirely you know and that was a
surprise you know that they were so
overtly the language of religious war
you know I don't mean an actual war I
mean religious conflict between cultures
I remember one of the senators saying to
me with real anger that the thing that
really annoyed him about the sama bin
Laden was that Osama bin Laden said that
America was a godless country
how can he say he said we're credibly
godly I said well senator I guess he
doesn't think so
but so it struck me then that what was
happening was a religious conflict of
this sign of offense - right I think
that's I think that's absolutely right I
think everybody there's fundamentalism
in this country and it takes all
different religious forms as it does
around the world but I guess the
question to be asked is at this point is
given the turmoil that the world seems
to constantly be drawn into which has
these religious sort of connections and
where free speech and other civil rights
are disputed in you point to a kind of
innate desire for openness and tolerance
and a life that reflects that do you
think there is also an existential need
that is not met by that kind of life
yeah yeah and and that there's something
in whether it's paradoxical or whether
it's explicable or what but I mean
there's there's it's not simply a world
where there are enlightened people with
commitments to freedom of speech and
secularism and so on and then the rest
of the world that somehow just doesn't
quite get it life is built a lot more
complexity in this and there are deep
existential needs on the other side
toward you myself field the world
spiritual should be outlawed for about
50 years because makes me think of naked
Californians on mountaintops
the chanting in Tibetan you know in
order to be in touch with the cosmos or
don't you just ban it so much for free
speech right I was gonna hike believe me
I caught it so go ahead but I think
what's different is this politicized
religion that's that's that's a that's a
religion with the backing all right
highly organized political movements
which you know after all when they take
charge in various countries have been
shown to be first of all not
representative and secondly
catastrophically bad at doing the job so
in those countries where religion has
actually taken over the government right
no Taliban Afghanistan
you know Khomeini I'd Iran it's a
catastrophe and I we look at you run
Iran before the fellaini Revolution I
mean you know and I hold no brief for
the show by the way you know one of the
world's great bastards and the budget
plate you know and the British and the
Americans fault you know the shower so I
mean let's I'm not trying to be you know
what they what be what I sometimes hear
being called a Persian the shara faction
you're they're always pleasures after
the show at the time of the change the
time the Khomeini revolution Iran had
Iran with a net exporter of food to the
region
it was extremely wealthy and developed
economy one of the most developed in the
third world had a very powerful trade
union movement and a highlighter highly
developed feminist movement it had a
broad range of political parties
starting from the Communist Party and
going to kind of free market capitalism
on the other side it had a very highly
developed educational system all these
groups joined to depose the show right
and and without the without all these
groups you know combining the shower
would not have been deposed
and the tragedy of either of Iran is
that Khomeini April every year right but
he basically destroyed all those people
who have brought into power in order to
impose very narrow society and since
then
Iran is a economic basket case you know
a whole generation has been wiped out
you look at a useless war there are food
riots because instead of exporting food
to the region there's no food in the
shops for people to eat the you know the
economy is a catastrophe right so they
can't run the country right and that's
of course why in Iran now they're very
unpopular now but if there is this
existential tension I want to pick up on
India and the sort of secular state of
Nehru and and the kind of state
socialism versus the movements of the
past decade which are representative
changes throughout the world and that is
the sort of globalized free trade and
the question is I suppose the question
is are you concerned on this kind of
striving to resolve these tensions we're
talking about are you concerned by what
you see in societies that you know well
by the shift to a market-based form of
life so that free speech is life itself
and that's become markets or life itself
it's a big shift as you say because
India came into being with a pretty
protectionist economy you know tariff
barriers around with a command economy
you know where the government made these
five-year plans you know auto rather
soviet model which the economy was then
supposed to respond to with a lot of
stimulation from above you know things
were done like for example I mean
famously Coca Cola was banned in India
so that local cola drinks you know could
emerge it was became illegal to import
foreign cars so that there could be an
Indian motor industry right and and so
on right and and that's how the country
proceeded yes for 30 years more than
unaligned non-aligned
relationship with the Soviet Union than
with the United States right in those
days the United States used to rather
suspect India because of that Soviet
connection and in Henry Kissinger's
phrase would tilt towards Pakistan and
that clearly was created mutual
suspicion right between between India
and the United States so a lot of which
actually was dispelled with at the time
the Clinton visit so that was right
beneficial effect of that right anyway
and then there's this huge shift right
huge which is a shift that happened
everywhere in the world that's right the
dropping of tariff barriers right the
result of that I wouldn't say has been
all awful yeah you know I mean just look
at one of the benefits at that time in
the time of the of the command economy
in the protectionist economy there was
very tight censorship of news media
particularly broadcast media you know
the print media were more or less
allowed to function but that's but the
broadcast the radio you know everybody
listened to in television as that became
more important completely controlled
then along comes the star satellite
Rupert Murdoch right beaming down you
know CNN MTV etc etc right and suddenly
there was a way for people in India to
receive news information right which the
Indian state could not censor right and
it completely transformed the nature of
the Indian media almost overnight yeah
you know that the ability of the ability
of the pret of the government to control
information vanished right no vanished
overnight and of course then then comes
the internet and it exponentially
increases that that's that so
so there's a sense in which there have
been clear benefits there's also been an
enormous quantity of wealth creation as
a result of I mean stunning number of
Indian millionaires I mean really quite
remarkable number of people of great
wealth in Indiana and and those people
are generating a very powerful economy
now and particularly in new technology
areas and so on but
you know I mean Bombay for example was
always a city of great wealth and great
poverty was always you know that the
slogan that cliche in Bombay was the
hope was about Havel and the high-rise
right next to each other and and that
was always there but now Bombay has
unbelievable well is this an all is this
all unbalanced for the good or you're
troubled by it has that that Gulf that
widening gulf between the rich and the
poor is the thing from which populist
crypto-fascist politics has emerged
elsewhere in the world you know and it's
that's where it comes from India if you
look at the growth in Bombay
specifically of the neo-fascist
political party the Shiv Sena it grew
entirely by understanding that the
important thing was to work at the
detailed grassroots level you know if
you went to the Congress party and you
add validity were a slum dweller
I mean arrivee biggest lamination in
Bombay it's not quite what people might
think of his Islam I mean it's got roads
it's got electricity you know it has its
got some plumbing in various places
stand pipes and so on you know so but
people are living in shacks made of tin
and cardboard in very dreadful
conditions if you're standpipe starts
what stops working you know there's no
drinking water
nobody would dream of going to the
Congress party guy because he only comes
round at election time he wants your
vote but the shifts saying a guy would
say okay and that afternoon there'd be a
plumber around there he'd fixed the
standpipe this is exactly how the Nazi
Party started exactly huh and they
understood that indy and learnt that
lesson if you work at the grassroots
level you're the guys who are there and
deliver you start building a power base
then they actually structured themselves
exactly like the Nazi Party and you know
as using I mean both are a the leader of
the ship said I famously would have a
picture of adult Hitler on his desk you
know as a role model so that's what
happened in Bombay and it's now it's
it's created a degree of communal
tension yeah that never used to exist
that it's very extremely worried
we have one more question then we have
to close and I'm going to quote one of
your statements this is the optimistic
side of your statement a self
description in your talk in Colombia at
low library in 1991 and the question I
want to read this and the question is do
you still feel this is an accurate
self-description you say yet I must
cling with all my might to that
chameleon that Shimura that shapeshifter
my own soul must hold on to its
mischievous iconoclastic out-of-step
clown instincts no matter how great no
matter how great no matter how great the
storm if that plunges me into
contradiction and paradox so be it I've
lived in that messy ocean all my life I
fished in it for my art this turbulent
sea was the sea outside my bedroom
window in Bombay it is the sea by which
I was born and which I carry with me
wherever I go
yeah I mean you know one of the things
it's I guess there's a very last thing
to say is it I think the freedom art
literature these are not tea parties you
know these are not quiet civilized
locations you know these are turbulent
brawling you know arguing abrasive
things you know you don't you know a
free society is not a society in which
everybody neatly says after you know
after you you know it's one in which
people on that level isn't it good that
people in New York have started being
rude to each other again I mean I
thought after you - after you how you do
that you all right all that stuff I sort
of good work what's that about you
anyway so I've always seen all these
related things you know democracy
freedom literature the world of the
imagination the world of the intellect
etc as being turbulent places and you
know out of that turbulence comes work
and you know out of those sparks you
know fly which are sometimes creative
and sometimes not you know but without
that turbulence you know in a calm sea
nothing happens so you know let's have
the storm so I want to say on behalf of
Columbia solving we look forward to
welcoming you back in 2015 12 thanks
very much for this
you